حقيقه انا احب ان اوضح واحد من الازمات
الفكريه في عالمنا العربي هذه الازمات
التي نجدها تظهر في الخطاب الثقافي
والاجتماعي في احوال المجتمعاتنا العربيه
هذه هي الطريقه السلبيه في التعاطي مع
احداث التاريخ وحضور السجال الطائفي
والعقائدي والديني في كثير من جوانب
حياتنا يعني تجد ان لما تاتي فكره جديده
نظريه جديده علوم حديثه بدلا من ان نتناقش
في لب الموضوع نجد ان السجال ديني او
عقائدي او حتى طائفي ياخذنا الى زاويه
بعيده جدا عن هذا الموضوع ثم ندخل في حوار
عقيم بلا ثمره وبلا فائده بل قد يزيد
الفرقه والشقاق ونبتعد عن الموضوع ذو
الفائده هو ابرز مثال على ذلك احداث
التاريخ مع الاسف الشديد في عالمنا العربي
التاريخ بدلا من ان يكون مصدرا للثراء
والجمال والابداع واستلهام القصاص والعبر
وانتاج الاعمال الدراميه والروايات
الادبيه اصبح حلبه للصراع حلب اهل الشقاق
حلب اهل الشد والجذب تستدعى شخصيات من
الماضي افضت الى بارئها قبل 1400 سنه ثم
نتصارع حولها لماذا هذا لن يساعدنا ابدا
في فهم احداث التاريخ بل قد يسبب في
انفصالنا عن تاريخنا هذا تراثنا هذا جزء
من حضارتنا جزء من من هويتنا هذا الشقاق
والسجال لن يفيدنا الا في انفصالنا عن
تاريخنا ويساهم في تشويه وان يكون تاريخنا
ملبد بطبقات من غيوم الصراع الديني
والطائفي